[Musique]
l'action flamme olympique c'est un
relais à vélo de fausses flamme
olympique du coup entre les associations
du collectif des nouvelles de france
pour rappeler l'urgence à agir pour
faire des jeux olympiques et
paralympiques cyclables donc on
interpelle arrive 1024 l'état et les
collectivités à mettre en place au plus
vite un vrai plan d'action thor pour djo
cicad
[Musique]
l'objectif c'est de rappeler que les
jeux sont une formidable opportunité
pour développer le vélo en ile de france
l'enjeu est que les spectateurs puissent
accéder au site à vélo de manière
sécurisée c'est un enjeu d'efficacité et
d'image efficacité pour que les
spectateurs puissent utiliser le vélo
s'ils le souhaitent les transports en
commun qu'ils seront bien remplies et
d'image pour montrer que l'ile-de-france
qu'un objectif de neutralité carbone en
2050 est une région cyclable dans un
moment où tous les projecteurs seront
braqués sur elle les yvelines c'est le
deuxième département qui accueillera le
plus de sites olympiques on en réseau
cyclable pour un sport qui est souvent
interrompues et les jeux sont un
accélérateur pour résorber ses coutures
les deux relais partiront de la
courneuve en seine saint denis et
d'elancourt dans les yvelines ils se
rejoindront à paris au pont d'iéna et
pour les épines on va passer dans devant
plusieurs sites olympiques donc la
colline d'elancourt le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et château de
versailles notamment avant de continuer
vers la ville puis sèvres et paris
[Musique]